[Music]
my talk is on pickling and embellishing
widgets first let me explain what these
two terms mean pickling basically refers
to having an efficient format to store
the user-interface separately from the
application this way when the
application is run all this information
can be easily converted into the
application
the embellishing refers to a given
graphical detail similar to some of the
information we've just heard where we
can add little bits of rectangles
vectors and stuff like that to add more
realism to the user interface what I'm
going to do briefly is to first show a
short movie then I like Spain to explain
some of the principles involved then
I'll describe the widget editor and the
way I handled the embellishing then I'll
explain some of the pickling and the
storage techniques used then I'll go
over some further X toolkit extensions
which I'd like to see implemented and
then finally I just have a quick summary
okay
I hope you can see play
I'm gonna show on this tape somebody use
their interface capabilities that we've
developed here
first thing we're going to show is a
product called laboratory workbench the
data acquisition
the first thing I'm gonna do is develop
is to build a simple data flow diagram
so I'll pick up the instruments I want
to use to create this particular diagram
yeah music just a simple test signal in
a scope
I'll connect these together
when I run it I get a graphical display
of the data the graphical display I
should control the number of
capabilities you can resize the screen
move things around
and you can change change the control of
the information that you're seeing now
we're going to show a little bit more
complicated instrument which will
highlight some of the output
capabilities of our current user
interface
this particular data flow diagram
consists of a standard plot and also a
DB plot there's an analog input scope a
power spectrum
and XY plot
currently it's taking input from a
microphone and displaying it both as
regular input and also after the power
spectrum on the right plant
with the interface we're able to
manipulate the visual characteristics
while the data is being taken in so that
the application is actually running full
blast while I was able to control user
interface and change parameters of the
program actually shorted out there for a
second by touching the back of the
microphone
this is an example of some of the
buttons we've created using our object
editor as you can see these buttons have
a little bit more graphical detail than
you would normally need we find that
this type of detail provides more
realism and gives a user more of a feel
for soft machine approach and more of a
natural tendency to understand what's
going on in the first button we have a
sub object that's actually the object
that's being lit lit or unlit depending
upon the condition of the button control
the second object has a backlighting
which lights up is if there was a light
bulb behind the button and the third
object when it selected the color
changes showing that we can change the
characteristics of the object the fourth
object is actually also a tint lighting
or a backlighting object but the NTSC
didn't quite provide much help this last
object shows the use of using an
indirect object to show the condition of
the button
now we're going to show some slide dolls
that we've developed as you can see the
thumb on these particular dials has a
lot of graphical embellishments and as
you move the thumb as you move the thumb
up and down the graphical embellishments
track we actually here use a sub widget
for that here's a further extension
where we actually put a numeric display
widget on top of the thumb and also
include the graphical embellishments
now we're gonna look at the scope that
we had in laboratory workbench first
we'll show you that that's made up of a
bunch of different fields this is a
label field and also it's you move bar
that's a numeric that tells us which
scope it is that's the actual scope
display area over here is a essentially
a prompt to field that gets updated with
various information from the application
here we have some controls that concent
back to the application a slide dial
some more controls a resize box another
prompt area and another scroll box
giving us quite a lot of information
that's controllable by the user on this
one particular widget the widget can be
enabled and moved and resized and a lot
of the parameters actually manipulated
wild in the widget editor
now we're going to disassemble the parts
to show that it's actually made of a
bunch of chemical components that are
hierarchically layered together to
create the composite widget
now we're going to create a simple
pulldown menu here we decide to select
how many entries we want we have seven
entries we define the area for the
pulldown menu now we're going to create
a horizontal menu defined for entries
for that and to find the area for that
menu now we're going to rename the
pulldown menu as a convenience
finally we tie the pulldown menu to the
horizontal menu then when we activate
the horizontal menu the pulldown menu
acts as we'd like
okay that's it thank you for watching
our video tape now I should quickly
mention that that wasn't using the exit
orchid and basically this is an internal
user nervous system that we developed
and we've used that for laboratory
workbench one of the products we
released and otherwise we still haven't
really released that as a product so
what we want to do is basically provide
those sort of capabilities for the X
toolkit so our basic goals are to have
user interface provide a high degree of
flexibility in the graphical
representation and also make it easy as
possible for the user interface to be
developed everything that you saw in the
movie was basically created
interactively from the user interface
editor there's a few concepts that are
important in order to make this easy to
do the first is the separation of the
application from the user interface this
then since then lets us keep the user
interfaces data which then can be
modified either using a graphical widget
editor or using languages and those sort
of representations the further extension
we sort of provide although this could
be argued is we like to separate the
semantics from the graphics this lets us
then have a course set or a generic set
of widgets which can provide a great
deal of graphical flexibility the also I
sort of believe that graphical
representations in some sense cross
semantic boundaries and a an example of
this is you could have a receiver where
you have a lot of buttons that all look
similar a lot of them they act quite
differently where one maybe a momentary
button and one may have little lights
above it that tell you what mode you're
in and so in general certainly it's a
good idea to make your graphical
representation snap your semantics but
in in reality there may be cases where
you want to have more flexibility to not
really create the policy the X toolkit
programming interface does do a lot of
good things it provides a runtime
creation of the user interface it
separates the application from the user
interface the one slight drawback is
since you are creating the the actual
user interface at run
I'm you do have to have exit II create
widget type calls in your application to
do that it handles the graphical layout
automatically which is certainly quite
nice and it provides a nice level of
control over the graphical appearance
using the X defaults file and the
resource manager the one drawback is the
graphical flexibility really isn't that
great further there's a few problems
with creating a runtime on the user
interface the most prominent is is a
complexity of the user interface it gets
more difficult as you can see in
laboratory workbench it becomes more and
more difficult to actually provide this
sort of capability using runtime calls
in an application now so it's more
difficult to share the user interface
between separate applications because
you have to go into source code and pick
up pieces of source code now the ideal
environment to me is just for the
application to register a bunch of
functions similar to the deck widget
editor what I have is a X T register
function call where you give a function
pointer an ASCII name of the function
you just have a string of functions that
you register that way when the
applications user interface is loaded
the names of the particular functions
could be mapped to their actual pointer
and this way you can just have the
application register the functions user
interface take control and everything's
done for you in order to provide these
capabilities using the widget editor
this gives us an interactive way to
create the user interface lets us create
the layout of the user interface the
structure in terms of the hierarchy of
hell that widgets are defined and the
semantics of the particular widgets as
well as the graphical details that any
particular widget may have we also
provide a mechanism to store the user
interface separately so that then the
application can load that up when it's
run and finally by using these type of
capabilities it makes it a lot easier
for the user to experiment with
different types of user interface
representations and do it a lot quicker
because they don't have to go into the
application and make modifications and
recompile it and relink
in order to provide the graphical
flexibility we use the notion of
displaylist widgets a displaylist is
prefect ly similar to a set of X since X
calls which is executed in order and
provides some sort of graphical image on
the screen the nice thing is in the
general widget structure is fairly
flexible but the display list gives us a
lot I'm a fairly inflexible excuse me
but the display list gives us a lot of
flexibility in terms of what's actually
stored there and in order to provide a
mechanism to provide the various states
of the widget we basically provide
various or multiple display lists and
this also gives us a little bit more
flexibility because the different states
can have quite varying graphical
representations so one quick thing is in
order to make this a little bit more
feasible by the widget editor we provide
a mechanism where all the different
widget states can be provided at once so
that you can create one widget state and
then copy to another then copied to
another and make modifications as you go
so it's easy mechanism to go between the
various display lists of the widget
editor the format of the display list is
then basically just the OP code and then
some data another op code and then more
data the op codes tell the user
interface system what registered
routines to use to operate on that data
so the user interface in some sense
intrinsics although they certainly at
the X X toolkit intrinsics but the
internal user interface information
doesn't really know have to have to know
if what the representation and that data
is the benefits of this mechanism are
that it gives us a much more greater
graphical flexibility it separates the
graphics from the source code so Americ
going back to the application to change
the graphics which is currently how the
widgets are implemented in the toolkit
it's a symbolic representation so you
can go in with it widget editor and
similar to make draw
move vectors around move rectangles
around and have all that information
symbolically there it's extensible I'll
briefly go over a mechanism we have to
add new instructions easily to the
display list you don't have to go
mucking through a bunch of code to try
to implement new information and it
provides a great deal of end-user
flexibility
that you don't have to give the end-user
source code or linkable code but by just
giving them a widget editor they can go
in and make changes to the user
interface there's a few enhancements I
make to the displaylist one is in order
to make it version tolerant besides
having an opcode we we proceed that by a
length field the length field is the
basically length of each opcode this way
when we store a particular user face on
disk in a efficient binary format we may
have 100 widgets all stored together and
perhaps someone was working on a system
that was a little newer than another
system and happened to use a couple of
instructions and weren't recognized by
the application we're currently running
by having this length field in there
it's easy for the system to skip over
information it doesn't know and then
basically gracefully you know skip
information that it doesn't understand
how to use slight might be a little
complicated but basically there's one
problem with using displaylist when
everything is an integer based is it is
in the X toolkit and that is if you take
the widget and then slice it real small
and then size it real large again
everything sort of energy truncates that
when you size the logic and everything
shifts over into the wrong place so the
way around this is we provide a floating
point as well as the binary
representation in the internal format of
the displaylist this way when the binary
when the displaylist is stored on disk
in an ASCII format user can edit the
actual integer values quite easily but
when it's loaded we use floating-point
numbers between 0 and 1 to provide
scalings from the top-left corner of the
widget down to the bottom right corner
so when the resize routine comes through
for any particular instruction it can
use these floating-point numbers to
recreate the integer values that can
then be used by the redisplay routine to
efficiently display the widget we could
have gone straightly with a
floating-point description but then
there's the issue of what you're really
doing is then resizing the widget when
you display it every time and it's a
just a performance issue basically in
order to associate the display lists'
with widgets we just associate them
directly with the widget in this in the
files they're stored in initially I was
going to use the resource manager and
have a notion of subclass for the
various graphical descriptions but I
found that for efficiency reasons and
just for
user convenience it's easier to do it
this way this way the user can go into
an ASCII file and edit particular widget
and pieces of information if necessary
although usually they'd use the widget
editor and also not only can they ever
edit the layout but they can also then
represent the graphical representation
quite easily and then finally for
performance it's easy to just load this
one database instead of having to merge
a number of databases together the
actual display instruction routines that
have to be registered are ascii load
which converts the ascii representation
into a binary representation ascii save
which converts the binary representation
back to an ascii representation a resize
routine which when called basically
resizes that particular instruction a
display routine which which provides the
various ex calls required to display it
and then there's some optional editing
routines that are used inside the widget
editor so it's easy to create the actual
instruction from the editor so in order
to register new instructions in the
display list we first create a unique
ASCII name for the particular
instruction then we create a non
conflicting opcode or index for that
particular instruction and then we
define and lists the various routines
required to implement the particular
instruction this is sort of a simplified
example of the type of ASCII file that
would be used to register for for
instructions for a particular display
list we have on the left you have the
particular opcode then you have the
index then you have the load binary load
instruction the resize and the display
these three routines are actually the
only ones really necessary for the
actual runtime application the widget
editor uses the ASCII representations
and then when it's saved converts them
to a binary representation which is more
efficient for running the application
err on time
now I'm going to talk about the pickling
of the widgets first I'd like to define
a few terms the first is the notion of
an obedient widget right now we have
something called a button box widget and
in theory if you have a button box
widget with a bunch of children you can
just have those children on man
and the geometry manager shouldn't shift
them around but at least in a latest or
one of the releases a little while back
if you do that in its a little 10 by 10
square and it doesn't do you much good
so I basically created an obedient
widget which when you place the widget
on top of it it doesn't Riaan you do
scale that widget it just scales all the
widgets inside it uniformly the primary
widgets are basically all widgets that
are on top of this obedient widget well
let me also back up and say the
top-level widget in our current X
toolkit doesn't provide multiple
children so we have to have this button
watcher this obedient widget on top of
that to provide the multiple children
that's required so the primary widgets
are all children of below that level or
without that one level below below that
this allows us to have a two tiered
directory structure for the user
interface the first level gives us all
the application information in terms of
an archive file where we can store a
binary representation and have a
concatenated archive representation and
also that all the sub directories for
all the primary widgets we don't
continue the directory hierarchy beyond
this level because we find that becomes
a little bit more difficult for user to
peruse through and usually at this level
of breakdown it's quite easy for the
user to look at an ASCII file see what
children it has and then open up one of
those children and see what children it
has and do that all in the same
directory so it's a nice level of
partitioning without making it too
difficult on the user so I've sort of
mentioned a little bit there's two types
of representations provided one is the
ASCII representation which can be edited
by an ASCII editor if necessary this is
partly used so that people that if the
widget isn't working right or they just
don't understand what's going on they
can always look at the ASCII
representation and then decide or see
just what's going on the binary
representation is used for performance
inside the application so that when it's
loaded it doesn't take a great deal of
time for the application to load all
these user interfaces and to further
improve the efficiency we can
concatenate all of these binary
representations together with the
archive facility so that you only have
to do one file open to read in all the
widgets that you're use
here's a brief example of the ASCII
storage layout the first thing you can
see well maybe I'll use this thing oh
and don't want to go blind trying to
turn it on the first thing is the
semantic information of okay just
shooting it at the moon I guess the
first piece of information is the
semantic information of the class
information about the widget the second
piece of information is the general
widgets layout structure the you know
where the widget is placed this is
relative to its parent widget the third
piece of information is basically and
then the rest of this piece right here
is all related to the displaylist
information the first piece tells us how
long the display lists' is going to be
in the binary format and then we have
basically something similar to X calls
although these can be flexible that
actually define the graphical attributes
of the particular widget and then
finally have some structural information
which provides us with the children for
the particular widget and notice I have
a command here with some children on it
okay now I'm gonna talk a little bit
about some of the extensions that I'd
like to see put in which would help aid
realism the first is what I call an
indirect visual response and in this
type of widget the actual widget that
you're pressing doesn't change its
graphical representation greatly it may
provide sort of a set on highlighted
unhighlight about it's that onset
wouldn't be implemented it would
basically then kick off to another
widget which actually changes its state
graphically and this is certainly
similar to when you have a receiver or
something and hit the power button and
the little red light goes on and it just
provides a mechanism to add more
modeling capabilities also here you can
see the use that we added this extra
rectangle a few vectors here and that
sort of stuff just these are the sort of
embellishments I'm talking about just to
give it more of a real feel I was
debating whether to show this one this
is a basically composite command class
widget where you have a sub widget which
is doing essentially the same thing as
the indirect visual response the reason
I didn't want to show it is because I
can actually do this with the multiple
display list there could be cases where
instead of it just being something
simple like this you might want to have
a numeric or some other sort of widget
on top of it so in general I believe it
would be important to loosen up a little
bit on the structure of some of these
lower-level widgets so they could handle
at least one child which it possibly
with a very simple obedient geometry
manager okay there's a few other
considerations in terms of things like
laboratory workbench it's important that
there's a mechanism so that the
application can provide events to the
widgets in a very efficient manner and
also it would be nice for input widgets
to actually send data not only to the
application but also back to other
widgets and to do this transparently
from the application so that these
supports the sorts of capabilities can
be modeled within the widget editor and
finally standard definitions should be
should be provided so that if you have
two different types of two-dimensional
graphs but that represent the data in a
different format it would be easy to
swap one widget out with another widget
without having to go back into the
application and change the event
structure or change other structures
and yet again here's sort of a further
extension to the to the sort of generic
widget mechanism and that would be a
mechanism or the semantics of the widget
are the same but the actual display
routine use may be quite different so
you may have a display routine that used
a display lists' one that uses of pics
maps or a little film animation or one
that uses a hierarchical 3d
representation to actually store it and
it would be nice at the application
again didn't have to really understand
these things but that there was an easy
way to swap them out if the user desired
or the application user interface
developer desire there's a few areas of
further work currently graphical context
which in x10 just weren't so bad
create some problems so initially
they'll just be sort of a minimal
implementation of this the one place I
use pics map just for the insensitive
widget where I just set up the grey pics
map and then run through it but
otherwise I limited myself to basically
the foreground and background colors
although the border widths and some of
those would be quite easy to implement I
mean there's no support right now for
the pics map instructions and the
indirect visual response if I have a
chance and have the time I'd like to get
that implemented but certainly it'd be
useful to have and output widgets just
need to have a capability to provide
real time output capabilities and the
output widgets would be log histogram
pie charts stuff like that so in summary
the widget editor makes it much easier
to create the user interface it the
display list gives us much more
flexibility over the graphical freedom
of the particular widgets the display
list and the storage capabilities make
it easy to share user interfaces across
applications and keep the user interface
separate from the application also
allows the end user to have much greater
control over the user interface and
another one other area I should mention
that was mentioned in the toolkit talk
is the issue of color maps and that's
one area where where work needs to be
done right now I just stick with the
standard color maps that the system has
and used them but for instance when I
was showing those backlighted widgets
and stuff like that it would be nice if
there was structure in the color map so
that you would know what colors to use
to use tint lighting and the very
visual effects like that they still have
time it's okay there's a few areas that
I discovered briefly one is similar to
the constraint widget
instead of doing uniform scaling you
could also do scaling of the information
inside the widget where you use the
notion of anchors or similar notion
where you actually tie a particular
graphical attributes of one part of the
widget to another part of the widget so
that you can scale things inside the
widget non-uniformly an example of this
would be if you had a picture frame
around a widget and then you want it to
resize that widget you may not want the
picture frame to actually resize but
just to have the lines on the sides and
the and the bottom to stretch out and
that's basically a sore any questions
[Applause]
well the widgets you've created and the
widget editor how will they be made
available to the ex community yeah I'm
actually going to try to provide a fair
amount of this as public domain software
the big problem I have is one problem is
by doing this talk I ended up spending
three weeks trying to get the slides
together so it's I was hoping to have it
all on the next release of the tape and
I'll try to have some of them on that
release but I do expect to provide a
simple widget editor and provide these
sort of capabilities so that others can
use them and actually we're doing this
in part because we're a small company if
we tried to build our own toolkit that
goes one direction and the rest of the
standard goes another direction that
just makes it more difficult on us so
we'd like to see the standard use some
of the capabilities we use that you know
hopefully will help out everybody any
other questions
okay okay go ahead what are the
performance cost of using pickled
widgets instead of hard-coding you'd say
that again what how much does it cost
you to use pickled widgets instead of
just hard coding okay well one thing is
by using oh that
well first back in the old days when we
first implemented it we use just asked
you would just and then it would take 10
seconds or 15 seconds for it to load and
we're talking about a hundred or 200
widgets well that was no good then we
went to binary widgets oh well then
we're down to four seconds or maybe
three seconds it's still no good so then
we went to this single archive file
where all the widgets are basically in
one file and actually I shouldn't say
all the widgets only the widgets that
are really used initially in the system
things like help buttons or
documentation boxes can be demand loaded
so this binary form the binary
representation can be demand load it's
not all we just have to be in the
archive file but we get about oh I would
say under a half a second too low at
about a hundred widgets but this is
using our old system in fact one thing
I'm concerned about is going to be the
performance characteristics under the X
toolkit and I haven't gotten that
completely haven't had any very large
you know examples to really see what
that's going to do once you have it
loaded what is it caught as is it any
slower than just directly calling the
widgets I don't think so at all because
basically the only real difference is
traversing the disk
lalla stand that's very efficient and
the values are right there and so I see
actually no real no real performance
degradation at all they're the first the
questions I had are also our performance
you're saying it sound like you've
already answered my first question which
is that you're saying that the the fact
that you're exposed processing is now an
interpretive process doesn't cause many
major performance loss no I well in
current implementation I use jump tables
so that that index basically immediately
jumps to the functions required okay so
it's a very quick reference the second
is that is that it looks like a display
list approach inherently says that you
only do whole window widget redisplay is
not rectangle redisplay x' or partial
exposures of any kind hey I missed then
again can't deal with partial exposures
with a display list probably right right
okay
any other questions
okay thank you okay back it to a clock
sharp look at the back of your map for
lunch places there are a lot of you
maybe you want to try and stage how you
eat not all of those places are big
enough to hold you all
I have 20 copies
now this is the low-tech version of some
of the stuff we had this morning this is
a good deal less sophisticated than the
things we saw but it has some advantages
I think Wilson Swift isn't a bird in
this case it's the SPS window facility
toolkit our group that TRW is called the
soft system productivity program soon to
change its name and we have a whole
collection tools that we have called the
software productivity system which
includes editors and form fill tools and
things like that this past year we
decided that since we were starting to
migrate over to Sun workstations in
other workstation though it would be
nice to take our applications and get
them to run more or less as windowed
environments rather than on vanilla
terminals running under curses which is
the way they were originally written
because of the time and the way that x11
was distributed it was necessary to use
the old toolkit and run it under X 10.4
obviously the next step is to go to X
11th the ideas of the Swift toolkit was
to give specific user interface to the
applications programmers the tool kit
provides its own idea of what a dialog
box looks like and so on on the theory
that if you turn everybody into an
amateur widget maker you end up with
amateurish widgets so all the user
interface pop-up things are
pre-programmed and as a result we have
what we hope is a very simple user
interface that hides X as much as
possible this enables our applications
programmer to recast these curses
applications in terms of Window System
on the other hand as a - you obviously
get a very stereotyped set of
applications that you can produce with
this kit the idea is basically to try to
give a sort of kind of hemming semi Demi
Mac like sort of user interface and the
whole idea was inspired by the simple
tools Macintosh
erricka produced once again this was
just the old x11 toolkit and we tried
not to do much of anything because we
were in a hurry so we only used the
existing widgets the editable text
widget source code not source code but
source code for from X and H and X edit
got incorporated into it the cascaded
menu widget that was in the old tool kit
from HP was incorporated into it and
alert boxes and dialog boxes were
basically just form widgets we've seen a
lot of hello worlds it's kind of like
name that tune I can hello that world in
only five lines of code which is
slightly contrived example because the
main event loop is kind of concealed in
the alert call there that pops up the
hello world alert box so that's slightly
contrived but we'll see a more
reasonable example somewhat longer later
on because it's on the old toolkit
widgets virtually everything you see in
the user interface right now is what you
get from the old toolkit widgets in the
next version we will produce our own
widgets that come closer to exactly what
we want as standard across our
applications so you have text panes and
message panes which are text widgets in
both cases message panes the programmer
interface is a printf type call form
panes graphic panes button box panes and
pop up items menus which each pane can
have its own menu that pops up when you
hit the right mouse button cascaded
menus of course and we can turn on or
off menu items during the course the
operation so the menus are dynamic in
that sense more stuff pop-up boxes file
selection boxes on a Macintosh which are
kind of fun alert boxes which display
short messages and let the user
knowledge
knowledge and dialogue boxes which are
straight out of the old toolkit dialog
box widget here's a sample of the sort
of thing we get kind of recursive
because that's my tribal plan we have a
one of our SPP tools was a calendar tool
and the form fill-in program that the
calendar tool uses was redone as an X
application using the Swift library and
this is the sort of thing it produced
this was originally done as a purses
based application and a whole lot of
control stuff went away you didn't have
to hit very strange command keys to move
around from one field to another you
just had to move a mouse the Swift was
debug using a very simple mcpeet preview
program so here's here's a pop-up menu
example over there and you've all seen
the menu widget I hope by now so there's
nothing surprising there click on quit
then I guess in this case you would X
terminate
just wanted to see if you were paying
attention here's an alert box in case
you ask for a file that you can't open
and it requires an acknowledgment before
it goes away here's a dialog box this is
this is our ADA interface 2x
and once again it gives you a space to
type something in and print or cancel it
and the file selection box which is
actually kind of fun and it works pretty
much like the Macintosh file selection
box it lists the directories that are in
your current directory gives you a
directory name where you are lets you
click on one of the selections in the
directory that's a scrolled window by
the way so if there are more more things
in the directory you can scroll up or
down and when you click the file name
goes into the thing down into the Box
down there and you can click the read
file button or change your mind entirely
or you can simply type into the box also
there is as we'll see later
hooks in there so that you can have the
application programmer can easily select
just which file names get displayed
similarly to the way Macintosh
applications select their choice of
things to go up and dial into a file
selection window so I'm gonna go very
quickly through the routines that are in
in the library and you'll see that
they're all pretty simple and fairly
self-explanatory and we don't need the
details here anyway so I'll go through
them very quickly
there's nothing terribly surprising here
worth mentioning there's a default
generic tool icon or the application
considered so an icon based on the
bitmap file each tool is divided up into
one or more panes using obviously the
same widget these are all vertically
pained at the present so if you want to
divide into panes you say add pane and
say what kind of text pane whether it's
text form graphic which is just a
generic X window or button box not
another pane window
there are three kinds of pains that
require additional information to
initialize them Tech's pain requires
some mode information and what the
source of the text is message pains can
pass input that is typed by the user
back to you to an application function
so that function can be passed in with
the message pain call and graph pain is
what in technical terms is called a hack
and is just there to allow a generic X
window to be used by the application
when an expose event or something like
that gets sent to that window the
application is expected to know how to
redraw it and supplies a routine to do
it because one of our big applications
is a fill-in type fill in the blanks
type application form pains became very
important to us and you have two things
in them you have text fields and labels
text fields are rather complicated
things unfortunately and this is about
the longest call in the library so you
supply the name the name of the pain in
which they belong all these the
namespace in which all these things live
by the way consists of two of character
strings which are supplied by the
application at the beginning so you
supply the name of the pain and the
field and whether the user can type into
it or just read it what its source is
minor visual aspect of whether it's
highlighted or not how its scrolled in
the case of a field that is in a form
when it gets larger the field itself
might want to become larger or it might
want to scroll or it might want to just
remain the same size and not allow more
than one line or so so that works in
there too and finally need its location
which is specified relative to some
other widget that's in that form either
text field or label
labor fields are much simpler all you
supply as a string whether it's
highlighted and where it is and what its
name is I'm not a big fan of button
boxes I think they get overused so there
can only be one button box per tool and
that's real easy to change if somebody
shows that I'm an idiot
so the one thing that does removes one
argument from the Box button call so all
you do is supply the label for the
button the callback routine that's
associated with in what gets passed to
the call that routine
I think X the comment about X mhm if you
saw the xmh interface it has no less
than three panels of buttons on the
screen those can be I think eliminated
largely by pop-up menus and by file
selection boxes once the event loop
starts going then there are three
operations that can be performed
you can either if the application has
changed a string that's associated with
a text widget the text widget sort of
has to be told that that string has been
changed that's what text update does a
text widget that's associated with a
file might want to be saved back to that
file at some point the last two routines
do that message windows are very simple
you can do a prenup tune and I took the
dumbest possible approach to dealing
with printf in variable arguments and
stuff like that you get four of them the
idea is to keep it simple right field
text fields that are in a form have
pretty much the same operations on them
as text panes or tool windows
unfortunately because they live in a
different namespace they have their own
set of calls specifying menus is done
with a very simple call you give the
name of the menu you foreach item in the
menu you give its name
the string that is going to appear in
the label what type of label menu item
it is and what happens when you touch it
label items don't do much of anything
except they appear in reverse video
those are usually the first item in the
menu button items are just command
buttons cascade items from HP if you
move to the right-hand end of then they
pop up another menu which is named by
the last argument and D act items don't
appear at all and that's how you can
turn menu items on these the menu call
can be done at any time during the run
it doesn't have to happen before you
start up the event so here's a real
simple menu no surprises here and here's
what it looks like
the file selection boxes get popped up
by a function called get file name there
are four arguments and one is the
prompting message
another is the default file name that's
going to appear in the type inbox unless
you do something to change it
predicate is the name of a function
written by the application which takes
the filename as an argument who returns
true if that file name should be
displayed and that can be an arbitrarily
simple or complicated program it might
just check to see if the name ends with
dot C or it might actually open the file
and see if it has an appropriate magic
number or something like that
and that's what selects what will appear
in that scroll menu and at the bottom we
see an example of how it might be done
it returns null if the cancel button is
hit otherwise it returns the name that
was typed alert boxes just pop up a
message and let the user acknowledge or
negatively acknowledge there are four
different types of them which appear
slightly different on the screen and the
first kind is distinguished by the fact
that it only has a single button you
can't negatively acknowledge it
dialog boxes are produced by the
function called prompt which prompts the
user with a message default and a list
of buttons the list of buttons is a
single string which contains the buttons
separated by colons and when the
function comes back it returns what the
user typed into the dialog box and a
colon and which button he hit and then
there are two other functions called
dialog field and dialogue button that
picked that result apart and can be
checked to see both which button he hit
and what he typed so here's the low
world in a slightly more reasonable form
it has two functions that are invoked by
menu items one for saying hello and one
for getting out of the program and the
main window is a message type window
which is the second to the last argument
of tool setup and whenever the high
button is hit then another printf adds
hello to that message wind-up which of
course will scroll and so on
and when the quit button is head of
course there's an alert button that
alert box that pops up and make sure he
really wanted to do that okay when we do
when it was debugged make the macpaint
previewer you saw before was used and it
started off as a naked 10-point X 10.4
application and it had 150 lines of code
no toolkit calls no nothing 150 lines of
code plus the mccain stuff itself and
didn't do much of anything when it was
all done it had 135 lines of code and it
allowed you to ask for new files and and
read them in and all sorts of swell
stuff that was encouraging so we took
our x naive application programmer who
knew all about our filling library and
had him rework it and in two weeks he
finished which was very encouraging he
didn't have to learn virtually anything
about X which was a good idea because
the X manuals are kind of cumbersome and
the X toolkit is largely documented in C
the biggest problems he had had with it
were the fact that since it was a curses
application he couldn't really do
character based addressing the way he
would sort of like to he kind of had to
do dead reckoning on pixels also the
text widget sometimes didn't behave as
he would expect obviously the next thing
for us to do is to do it over again in
x11 the idea when it's done over an X 11
is that our application programmers
never notice that we've done that we
hope to have hidden X well enough that
it doesn't matter which X or which
toolkit it's running on as far as the
application programmers interface to it
also most of the pop-up items really
want to be their own widgets rather than
being hacked on top of the existing ones
of course we'd like additional things
too I'd like to talk to the gentleman
from CMU who had the
pixel-based of buttons those would be
nice for us real graphic applications
obviously are completely unsupported by
this you have to resort to raw X so as
some assortment of simple at least
operations that can be done in graphic
windows and kept track of by the toolkit
and redrawn by the toolkit would really
be useful then we ought to look into if
we've really hidden X well enough then
it shouldn't matter whether X is under
it or Sun view is under it or News is
under it or it's running on a Macintosh
so we ought to look into at least seeing
if we can make our applications very
very portable using this toolkit we hope
we can we're trying to keep it as simple
as possible for just that reason
one other thing to invest the thing that
we really need
I guess I should have mentioned it
earlier of course is popup windows that
give you all the switches and knob
typesetting things we don't have any
facilities for that in the current
toolkit and we're definitely going to
need that and that's all I have to say
[Applause]
how long how long did it take you to do
the first implementation on there X 10.4
started at the beginning of September
and was finished enough for the guy to
start working on the application around
the middle of November
trying to get it up there high because
they tend to just clip it on the belt
my name is Bob schaeffler no no it's
more delusions of grandeur I guess the
or not maybe yeah I'm going to tell you
about counterpoint which is a little
prototype system that a couple of us
have done at AT&T Bell Laboratories
here's a list of characters
I'm Doug Blewett and the Marcel meth and
Mike wish also work at AT&T in Bell Labs
Det Nugent is MIT co-op student that
helped us with the reason utility
package part of it so that's the that's
the talk the so this is this is kind of
a disclaimer slide I've got here AT&T
will have an X based product out in the
summer and this is a what we call our
6-3 86 box so it's a 83 86 box and the
the we have a whole bunch of people here
from AT&T and if you actually want to
talk to the developers who are doing
that I'm sure it wouldn't be too hard to
scare up not sure connect you with any
of them if anybody's interested in it
part of the reason that I bring that up
is that I want to make clear that
counterpoint is is only a research tool
you know there's no notion to sell this
thing it's we just did this for fun you
know it's it's not my fault
you know all those things don't tell my
mother you know that the so I you know
I'll I'll say that over and over again a
number of other times just a small
project that a couple of us have
attacked together now what one of the
things I'm kind of interested in is how
many people have actually used the X
toolkit xtk raise your hand not bad now
how many people actually like it keep
your hand up of those who so if you've
got two hands up you've you've liked it
and used it do we have any anybody with
just one hand up strangle those people
who are we I really like the tool kit
and you know I'm do these guys have
their hands up down here and these guys
from deck
now they're getting paid for it you know
interesting so here's a list of
motivations motivation slide and so we
have motivation for us and for you this
is what the system actually looks like I
know why I feel obliged to use that now
I'm gonna show you a little videotape
kind of a funny videotape that that I
act together one morning about actually
I think it started at 3:30 and I
finished at 5:30 so it's mainly
incoherent but you'll like it I think so
we have three major motivations and I
think there there are three things that
you could possibly get out of this talk
one is that you know 80 Bell
Laboratories in research especially
there's one thing that that we like and
that small is beautiful and so we want
to continue this notion of small
communicating processes and so
everything in in counterpoint is the
process and so the this is the display
that I'm coming up here so each of these
things is a separate process a real to
life unix process and these are just
regular old widget demo programs some of
them we've stolen from those guys at Dec
and others we've written from scratch
entirely ourselves this piece is a
reasoning utility package which is a
follows that small process model that
Thompson or Ritchie are always pushing
on us so it's about an eight megabyte
process
and we would actually we actually have
schemes for turning to each of those
into an eight megabyte process but
you know that's another story I guess
and then we have an application here
that communicates to those widgets
through the reasoning utility package
all of these things are hooked together
with IPC and we actually have some
interest in inter process communication
the demo that you'll see today is using
Internet datagrams and we use those
because they don't soak up a file
descriptor and one of the problems you
have here is you run out of file
descriptors so so that's extending the
UNIX philosophy of small communicating
processes we also do kind of a nice job
of blending in truth maintenance
techniques I think that you know I hope
you'll see that in there and I think we
also have some interesting widgets which
are kind of fun find toys Jai hope
you'll like the reasoning utility
package is thing we did so it's called
RUP and it's package that was written by
David McAllister and it's a truth
maintenance system which is just a you
know one of the schemes for doing
knowledge representation and at truth
maintenance for those who aren't up on
that into the businesses tends to be
kind of the winning edge for a knowledge
representation so it's a nice scheme and
it tends to be very fast you'll see in
the demo that the messages that we're
sending around are flying out of the
reason the utility package quite quickly
in and it's doing a lot of reasoning for
each message that it sends out on top of
the reason you use utility package we've
added a layer that does constraint
propagation similar to that too similar
to that of Abelson assessment assessment
and so it's constraint propagation so
when I put in an X value if I have a
equals x plus y Y is defined a
automatically gets generated that sort
of thing
and we have code attached so one of the
nice things about the reason utility
packages that you can have notifiers
so that whenever a variable is or when
particular condition arises it'll fire
off a bit of code for you and so we use
that quite heavily to send messages it
around to our widgets you'll see some of
that later we've added the following
functions to the reason utility package
so the notion here is that we set up an
assertion and we say that a and B are
equal and if A or B gets assigned a new
value then it will automatically
generate the other term and likewise we
have plus minus times